こんにちはドクターはじめだみんながハッピーターンというか知ってるか
それには魔法の粉がかかっていて1回取れてしまうとあたかも魔法にかかったように
延々と食べてしまう中毒性のあるとんでもないお菓子だ普通のハッピーターンがあるん
ですけどもちょっと前にこういうのが出ました
2社て50%パウダー max ハッピーターンこの菓子の周りにほな
パウダーがかかってこのパウダーによって味付けがされており1回食べてしまうとクセ
になるそのパウダーの量が20050%増量されているのがこちらのハッピーターン約
50のある黙って食べてみよう
voodoo
まあ奪いは困難だけでよくなるわけですよ
こんながすごいおいしいこのお菓子はパウダーが付いてしまったってんしゃす私
ドクターはじめハッピーターンのたーーーー大好きなんだみなさんの想像してる以上に
大好きすぎて私は何とかしてハッピーたのはこんなだけ or ようにまとめて食べ
たいと思ってしまったなぁということだ禁断のパウダーどんぶり
に飛べなくなってしまったなんて罪な男の話だったので日々の男あー
ウェイどれくらいですけど体で今回私はピーター210%パウダー max 俺だけ
ずれないでよ
[音楽]
ああああああ
はいというわけであピザ250%キャンプから集めました
これコンビニ原点なので本命に見入ったとしても売っててもなんか後6袋とか多くても
10袋ぐらいなので非常に手に入れるのが大変だった私は静岡つのコンビニを1日かけ
て集めもあった
それがその結果これだけに負わせるのにどんだけを費やしたことがあって本当にカーで
大変だったがようやくこれ
ダイハツミラれたので今回私の寿命化ネットにこのファイルのハッピーさあから私は
今回
パンガー体験を抽出しようと思うハッピーだろこんな作れるみたいな話もあるんですよ
塩と砂糖と味なことからポンとも馬鹿って何かあるハッピーターンの粉を調味料だけで
膨れてみたいな話があったんですけども
リーダー長いものにすぎんだろ私が食べられるは本物ハッピーターンとパウダー通り
まあ和え物などいらんふぁんさんだけを2サルベージしどんぶり一杯のパウダーを作り
1級に食べたいと思う
また一つ科学の歴史のページが開くするかファイターやっていこうともうハッピー
ダーワーちゃんの責任を持って食べます
こんな歯ブラシでハッピーターンについているパウダーをここに落としていくと良い
作成かなり数があるのでさだったという事抹茶を差し上げます
全然共通設定をする歯ブラシもハッピーターボパールを落とすために生まれてくるか
思ってないだろうねずっとああなんか意外といける気がしました
やっぱり150%というのが多分てかい気がしますねめちゃくちゃ押しますでは
どんどんやっていこう
[音楽]
地味だなぁん
ん
混ぜて阿呆でしょ
あ
[音楽]
ん
ません
持っていた
[音楽]
びっくりするくらいもするけど a
サッサッサッサっサシャさっちゃ
サシャえびばでぃ
手首ブレザーが降り増加だそれあっはぎズバッ
ハート入ってないんだよねめっちゃ悩んだろぅ
よっしゃの結構半待っているわけでございます
やばいよこのすごいオチョバー構図だ
メイドのご覧ください皆さんの10袋ぐ目ぐらいから全然出なかったんですけど
ようやくハート形のハッピーたが出ました
i ぐいぐいぐいぐいほんとイブ
そうだな
まあ一言で言うと
幸せの
折り返し
ですねまあ決して一人でできることとは思ってないし
いろんな人たちの協力があってこそ完成した実験だと僕は思います
やっているときはあまり幸せじゃなかったんですけどまぁいざ割ってみると
さんの幸せが
ターンしてきましたねみんなにも幸せが1兆族といいなと思っています
ありがとうございます
[音楽]
というわけで星
パッピーバーガーのサルベージに成功しました
本当に大変だなめてた100波では全部は使わなかったんですけどなかなかかなり56
袋ぐらい使って夜明け
どんぶり一杯の happy bird を通知することに成功しました何個か食べ
ちゃったんですけどもハートのハッピーターンが60袋中6個ぐらいしか出てないので
かなりの計画
いざということが分かりましたまあこのブラッシングアイテムを見る通りかなりの戦い
だったことが目に見えてわかると思います
どんぶり一杯のハッピーカードを抽出するのに役
3時間くらいかかります時間の無駄です本当に年中身全部これですから一切のアレが
もうない状態でございますこれ
ようやく念願のアサシン指を叶えるたっけきた目は早速
至福の時間をいただくとしますメジャー行きます
内田がな方とされますねとなります
ええええええ
goo
はあああっ
恋なぜだおいしくないぞねえこいこい声
何度ランガー
[音楽]
あうめぇ
me
ええええええ
あっはぁ
というわけで今回の実験でわかったこと
ハッピーパウダーは食べ過ぎる遠い少ないということが分かりましたくそ
てこのハッピーパウダーどうしようかといいますと今後の実験に使えるかもしれない
かなり重要います資源だ
こちらはカメラを敷きからのこれ防湿庫という私の部屋に研究室があるんだがその中に
湿らないようにして
カメラと一緒に入れておきます
[音楽]
ん
立っちゃったんだ